[Music]
hey everyone this video is going to be
fairly short and sweet and addresses a
question that had been requested in the
comment section quite a bit it surrounds
a battle in the order of the Phoenix
where Dumbledore and Voldemort fight
inside at the ministry atrium at one
point in their epic battle
Voldemort attempts to use Avada Kedavra
on Harry however what is unusual about
this segment is that Dumbledore is able
to successfully prevent Harry from being
hit by it in fact all of Voldemort's
attempts are using Avada Kedavra and
there are multiple are unsuccessful this
is interesting because we first learn
about the properties of Avada Kedavra in
the Goblet fire in class moody actually
Barty Crouch jr. is teaching the class
about the unforgivable curses and
clearly states there is no way to fend
off the killing curse so this begs the
question how did Dumbledore deflect an
undefeatable spell which I feel wasn't
communicated properly was the Barty
Crouch jr. never said that Avada Kedavra
was entirely unblockable he only meant
that it was unblockable by use of
counter spells in a jewel or fight a
common counter spell that one might use
would be something like potato in the
case of the killing curse however it
would go straight through the shield
charm and serve as no protection to the
caster this includes all other defensive
spells there simply isn't a way to
counter it with magic however you are
able to put the spell if you put a large
enough object between yourself and the
caster they're powerful
Vlada Kedavra cannot pass through large
objects this brings me back to the scene
in the order of the Phoenix where
Dumbledore successfully saves Harry from
Avada Kedavra
in actuality Dumbledore does not utilize
any kind of counter curse or counter
charm
he simply utilizes his magical
capabilities to move a large golden
statue in between Harry
Mort this is explained in the following
excerpt but the headless golden statue
of the wizard in the fountain had sprung
alive leaping from its plinth to land
with a crash on the floor between area
and Voldemort the spell merely glanced
off its chest has the statue flung out
its arms to protect Harry what cried
Voldemort staring around and then he
breathed Dumbledore in this part of the
book Voldemort actually uses Avada
Kedavra a couple of times and is
unsuccessful with each attempt page 813
States Voldemort raised his wand and
sent another jet of green light at
Dumbledore who turned and was gone in a
whirling of his cloak in this instance
Dumbledore simply evaded the spell which
is obvious and something that others
should probably also do sometimes page
813 again says Voldemort sent another
killing curse at Dumbledore but missed
here Voldemort just misses this requires
no work on Dumbledore's part then again
it says another jet of green light flew
from behind the silver shield this time
it was the one-armed centaur galloping
in front of Dumbledore that took the
blast here Dumbledore brought one of the
statues to life to absorb the blast I
think that the ease of murdering people
with Avada Kedavra is a little bit of an
oversight in Harry Potter you would
surely think that other cunning witches
and wizards might have utilized tactics
like evasion or blocking to defend
themselves from the killing curse but
all too often they fall victim to it it
may require a bit of premonition and
reflexes but if you're standing face to
face with Voldemort you can pretty much
assume that he is going to try and use a
body Kedavra at some point he really is
a bit of a one-trick pony sometimes with
that being said I hope this explanation
helped if you guys have a video idea
please let us know down in the comments
below until next time euro is it hard
[Music]